what's up you guys time for the movie
retrospective
so we're doing uh some more red and
exploitation exploitation whatever you
want to call it yeah so a little while
back we covered the splatter classic
2000 maniacs uh one of herschel gordon
lewis's
blood trilogy good movie and uh it was
yeah uh honestly you know it's it's very
uh crude on by today's dance came out in
1964 uh you know so if you want to watch
that review we did that before too but i
kind of got curious because i knew that
there had been
a remake sequel
something or other uh that had been done
in the mid 2000s that had robert england
in it and i just noticed that it was on
2b and i was just kind of like maybe we
should do that one too because i'm
really curious to see
uh how it came out yeah i didn't know
robert england did any documentaries
because that's what this is
this is a documentary on itself
it is this is actually
okay so i think because it was called
2001 maniacs i think for a long time
this was actually the first time i had
seen it
uh the remake
so i
guess that i mistakenly thought that it
was a sequel it's not really a sequel
it's more like a remake or like a soft
reboot yeah uh it's pretty much the same
story it's just kind of like updated and
tweaked a little bit more more comedy
more sex
uh yeah it's very very smutty and very
very gory hog hot chicks in it there
yeah yeah um and the good looking guys
if you're if you're some girl you wanted
for eye candy a bunch of
young people in it but she's trying
people
redneck girls with [ __ ]
pants all bunched up and [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah man those those uh those short
shorts were like way the hell up in her
yeah up in her cage this thing is so
historically accurate
all the costumes the accents are all
accurate
i'm [ __ ] with you well i mean i will
say um
that well some of the actors that were
in it like the guy that played like the
ashley wilkes like the the southern
gentleman type dude uh that dude is
actually
i think he's from florida okay and a
couple of other people that were in it
like the guy that played the dude that
was from connecticut but said no i'm
really from south carolina he's actually
from texas yeah so some of the people in
this were southern
and honestly um
robert england you know not southern but
he's just so fun to watch because he's
obviously having like such a [ __ ]
blast like hamming it up in this yeah so
you know so
i'm forgiving it he yeah he tries to do
like a southern aristocratic cracker
[ __ ] accent and he has a confederate
flag
uh which is pretty awesome yeah uh but
yeah so although i will point out again
that is not the confederate i knew you
were going to say that i mean that's why
i kind of like left again because i knew
you i knew you were going to like well
actually about that but everybody that's
what everybody calls it so that's just
what i call it i know that's technically
that's not good yeah it was a battle
flag of the north virginia army i think
but uh yeah so so yeah so i was thinking
the whole time before i had seen this
that it was a sequel because it was
called 2001 maniacs apparently the
reason they call the 2001 maniacs is
because originally this was supposed to
come out in 2001
uh you know the year but uh somehow you
know obviously this happens with movies
sometimes it kind of got pushed back so
it didn't actually come out until 2005.
so this was actually directed by tim
sullivan
who he hasn't done a [ __ ] ton of stuff
uh he made a movie called driftwood i
think the year after this and he was a
director on
that uh scream queens series that vh1
did
um but he started out as a
self-proclaimed monster kid so he
started out back in the early 80s like
working doing special effects and [ __ ]
like that um he actually shows up as a
cam there's a lot of cameos in this uh
movie as well so we'll kind of get into
that
but uh yeah so
i think this movie cost about three
million dollars it's pretty low budget
but it doesn't really look good it
doesn't really look it i mean you know
the the production design and stuff like
that it's very workman like they did
actually shoot it in georgia where it's
supposed to be taking place
and you know like you said some of the
costumes aren't period accurate and
stuff like that but like i said oh none
of them
yeah this is essentially just a sex and
gore farce it's a comedy yeah um and
it really
honestly i was surprised at how closely
it
it really kind of like hewed to the
spirit of the original yeah but they
just like upped the gore there's more
victims they tweaked a few things that
actually i'm gonna say improved it a
little bit because they actually it sort
of like makes more sense yeah in some
ways than the original did which
i think the original head had editing
problems i think some certain things got
edited out they forgot to mention
certain aspects of the story i think
yeah maybe or
it just didn't explain it real well all
the time but this is a better movie
inspired by the first one it's in the
same it's in the same spirit of it like
she said
the execution's a lot better it's more
modern
yeah
more entertaining it's more entertaining
the first one was entertaining because
you're looking and going man this is
1964. it was way ahead of its time yeah
big six for 64. i mean like i said it's
very crude right but but the gore and
the shocking the shocking elements of it
you know where they're just they're
they're
they're having
people laughing and having a good time
while they're killing people yeah i mean
[ __ ] because of the civil war it
really horrifying yeah
yeah
but yeah so i mean i yeah the original
one you could tell that you know he had
made h.g lewis had made blood feast
obviously before that but you could tell
that it was just kind of like we have
these fun gore scenes and we're just
like kind of hanging a movie around it
this one's kind of like that too but
i don't know it's so in that sense it
does like you know keep the spirit of
the original it's very very
uh
you know kind of
i don't know
if you say juvenile that sounds kind of
like negative but this is just like a
balls to the wall gory
you know there's titties everywhere yeah
there's like really like politically
incorrect uh jokes like jokes about
black people jokes about asians joking
about like there's all kind of [ __ ] like
that like jokes about gay men yeah all
kind of [ __ ] like that and it's just
unabashedly having a good time with it
nobody's taking it seriously everybody
looks like they're having a good time
making it yeah and consequently it's a
good time watching it rob zombie would
like this movie yeah this definitely
seems like
something kind of like imagine if
deliverance was a horror movie they had
a lot of hot chicks in it
they make deliverance jokes in the movie
too
yeah because there is one character who
has a girlfriend that's a sheep named
jezebel yeah and they have like a whole
bunch of jokes it's like a running gag
of him like running around like pulling
his pants up going she's playing hard to
get you know like that type of stuff so
yeah there's a lot of sheep [ __ ]
jokes yeah everybody
everybody is some kind of stereotype
yeah the ghosts and
and the yankees them too you know
they're they're all stirring yeah this
nobody's safe in this one this does kind
of have uh because i do kind of feel
like in the early to mid 2000s because
you know i i always say that i'm not a
big fan of
90s horror and i'm not a big fan of like
early 2000s i don't even know if it's
90s i think it's like mid 90s to mid
2000s because there were so many like
slasher knockoffs and so many remakes
this is a remake too but
to be honest with you i don't it doesn't
bother me as much that they remade this
because the first one even though it's
very iconic for being one of the first
of its kind a gore film um you know it
was so crude that it could really do
with an update uh one thing about the
mid-2000s though is that everybody in
this looks like
they should be in like nickelback or
something yeah like or who is the band
who is the shitty band that came after
that uh like nickelback i can't remember
but but that's like like no that was
before before okay that was like no and
foo fighters were actually good that was
the that was dave grohl from yeah i'm
just trying to figure out who you would
i'm talking about like kind of all the
douche rock bands like from like the
late 90s and why can't i think of any of
their names except for i'm not even
everybody is very very like uh blandly
you know good looking and they all have
like the the dudes all have the spiky
hair with the frosted tips and that kind
of stuff but see you're not really
supposed to i feel like you're not
really supposed to like any of the
college kids yeah because they're really
obnoxious you're not even really
supposed to like the black biker guy
you're not really supposed to like
anybody in this way i guess
he's the only one that looks different
from anybody else in terms of
stylistically he shows up on a damn
some kind of [ __ ] cruiser it wasn't
it wasn't a harley davidson he had a
chinese girlfriend
but he's all [ __ ]
buffed out and [ __ ]
[ __ ] he stood out the rest of them
like you said were kind of generic
yeah so what you have and you will you
can actually do something's up with the
ghosts he tried to fight he goes bad
there's something not right about this
you know i've never seen a towel without
a hot without hot black girls that's
just sliding where are the hot black
people
[Laughter]
well yeah and then and one of the things
too and this is what i mean about this
having like a lot of like quote unquote
politically incorrect jokes in it is
that when he shows up like one of the
first things that happens is that
there's another black man who lives in
the town and he like offers him a plate
with like a big slice of watermelon on
it yeah yeah yeah and the dude's like
what the [ __ ]
you don't really explain it he's a ghost
yeah he uh he he's uh the butcher most
of the time
yeah it's it's the same it was the same
guys that was the butcher right it was i
think you're in the bodies up yeah yeah
yeah and um i guess it just goes back to
the beginning of the movie where the
[ __ ] yankees are at university just
laughing it up during the history lesson
of the civil war and the
and the and the
and the uh the professor's like yeah
laugh it up you know what i mean in this
battle you in this battle you know what
what was it 90th or in this war was it
90 000. that was more than that it was
680 000. no you know you're talking
about how many innocent southern
civilians were just [ __ ] kill
slaughtered [ __ ] haphazardly so i
guess that that black guy was just one
of the people that the union army just
[ __ ] slaughtered haphazardly because
he was in there to get revenge that
ghost
interestingly yeah this has because i
kind of feel like the original
it just it has a little bit like where
it is establishing the characters and
then they get like to the town which is
called pleasant valley in this one they
have that little prology type thing with
some of the douchey college students in
the class now the teacher you asked me
about that because you were like oh man
that dude he's like in everything he
sounds german to me uh he's swedish
actually uh yeah his name is peter
stormair stormer stormari can't remember
how to pronounce his last good sign when
he shows up in the movie because i like
every movie i've seen he was in the big
lebowski yeah he was in john wick too
yeah uh lost world jurassic park the
lost world he was in like a [ __ ] ton of
stuff because i immediately like wrecked
tends to be in good movies yeah he was
shock a lot that's a good one he was an
armageddon he was in like a bunch of
stuff but uh yeah he's swedish actually
not german but he plays like pretty
because he has that indefinable accent
he always
plays germans or italians or whatever
um yeah so this movie also stars like i
said robert england who's playing like
the mayor role uh from the original uh
movie you also have lynn shea who i love
her and everything she's fantastic she's
in a [ __ ] ton of horror movies yeah she
was in uh dead end she's been in some of
the she wasn't she in some of the
[ __ ] conjuring or the insidious
movies or whatever she was in that she
and she just like um she looks like
she's having a [ __ ] blast too she
plays granny boone
in this and uh let's talk about some of
the cameos because there's a [ __ ] ton of
cameos in this
now uh first cameo that you'll probably
recognize uh is eli roth who was one of
the producers on this film as well
and he plays a guy who's inexplicably
throwing dead armadillos
on
on the car thing to get people to
come to the town i'm guessing well i
thought he was trying to sell window
window
cleaning oh yeah maybe that was his
grift yeah throw a damn it wasn't the
whole armadillo it was just a shell
yeah it didn't have like the answer but
it was still like bloody yeah the inside
that was yeah
yeah
yeah so eli roth turns up in this uh he
said later that the character that he's
playing in this is actually supposed to
be the same character is supposed to be
the character justin from his movie
cabin fever which you know very popular
movie which came out a couple years
before this uh there's also a cameo by
country singer travis tritt
who plays kind of like the redneck gas
station attendant yeah where the at the
gas station
yeah before they get there
uh there's a blink and you'll miss it
cameo by none other than kane hodder
uh who's basically just like holding one
of the victims and you just see him for
a second although if you look at the
credits um his name his character's name
is actually jason so he does actually
play one of the uh one of the townsfolk
and then there's also uh the director
tim sullivan makes a cameo as the guy
like hammer in the coffin
and i didn't even realize this because i
thought this dude looked kind of
familiar there's another cameo by adam
robitel who was the guy that wrote and
directed uh one of my favorite found
footage movies of all time the taking of
deborah logan and he also directed
escape room which remember we saw that
in the theater and uh insidious the last
key so he's in there as well so i
thought that was kind of cool so it's
like it's it's like kind of [ __ ] spot
the horror legend in this
um also this is super weird and i this
just goes to show how [ __ ] small the
world is
so the woman that's in this that plays
the milk jug
lady you know what i mean the one that's
making all the jokes about her jugs and
and whatnot
uh that's krista campbell and she's been
in a bunch of movies one of which
was the 2011 remake of the mechanic that
charles bronson movie that we were just
talking about the original the other day
yeah she was also in the wicker man
remake yep the bees the bees and the i
we should probably do that one of these
days
um but yeah so what happens in this
movie pretty much the same thing that
happens in the original movie which is
there's actually it's two carloads okay
one of the cars has three college kids
the other car has
two
girls and a guy
and then there's a motorcycle with a guy
and his girlfriend on the back now all
of them are heading down to daytona
beach my hometown for spring break
uh but they kind of get lost or off
track in georgia somewhere and uh just
as in the original movie you know they
have the sign like saying the detour
that leads them to this town
now uh in the original movie that's one
thing that i think that they kind of did
a little bit better in this one in the
original movie everybody just decided to
stay even though they were all like
heading somewhere to do like important
[ __ ] like hey i have a conference like a
work conference or something like that
why would you stay in this town for like
two days even if they did give you like
a free hotel room and stuff in this one
it's still not super believable but
these are just college kids they're
going to spring break they don't have
anywhere to be specifically and they're
just kind of like hey we're getting free
food and free hotel rooms and there's
hot babes here so okay whatever i don't
think the biker and his girlfriend were
college though no they weren't but i
think they were going down to dayton i
was i think they were still going today
yeah they were in like the convoy type
deal yeah
so so there is like a slightly better
reason for the people to stay in the
town
than there was in the original i will
give it that yeah
so uh so yeah so then the townsfolk uh
are very
old-fashioned let's call it that very
old-fashioned southern uh southern
hospitality there's kind of like all of
the stereotypes like like i said like
the inbred dude like [ __ ] the sheep
uh you know and various other things and
uh then all of the college students the
yankees start getting picked off one by
one
uh first of which
uh the girl
that's what's her name her name's cat
right because they call her like
pussycat she makes all kind of like
[ __ ] jokes yeah um now she gets pulled
apart by horses
which uh which actually happened to a
guy in the original but of course they
couldn't show it as much they just kind
of showed like a thing this one uh the
effect is pretty good i think that most
of the effects in this are practical
uh there is some cg and you can tell
because i think the one part where she
pulls apart i think that is
practical but like you know overlaid
with cg but it still looks pretty good i
gotta say so she gets pulled apart like
her arms and legs get pulled off and she
dies
and then um but there are some there's
some really good gore in this i really
like the one guy that gets killed
by the he gets killed by the milk jug
girl right where she like puts the she's
like oh i got some moonshine and she
puts the [ __ ]
tube down his throat yeah and it's
actually acid so it starts like
dissolving him from inside yeah and like
just hauls through the bed and [ __ ]
and what
what were you going to say missus you're
going to spoil all the kills on this
well no i'm just saying there's like
really good kills in it there's really
good kills in it you know and you get
one you get one guy who gets like
skewered like through the ass and like
out through the mouth yeah it's all kind
of it's all kind of like
people couple people get squished
they're all kind of getting punished for
their sins basically in a way
that's true it's it's it's
it's kind of like the first movie
where
they're kind of they're kind of killed
based upon what their personalities are
like and the [ __ ] that
the ghosts are punishing them for their
sins and you find out later that what it
is is that
they're trying to get even for all the
people that were massacred in that town
there were 2001 of them that had to be
massacred that's how many 2001
confederate citizens got
massacred so they got to kill two
rogue union yet yeah back in the civil
war yeah it says they were massacred by
rogue union
garrison or whatever whatever
uh [ __ ]
if you read the history they were all
kind of rogue it was [ __ ]
places [ __ ] chaos
and um
so they gotta kill 2001 to get even it's
an eye for an eye type of [ __ ]
and they did something else in this one
that i think like was better explained
than the original which is nice because
it's like this is just like a silly
horror comedy with just ridiculous gore
and tits
and you know
juvenile humor yeah um but i like that
they at least tried to like improve on a
couple things from the original here's
one thing that always bothered me about
the original the original was kind of
based on it was like a redneck brigadoon
in the sense that you know a hundred
years later
this town popped up as ghosts
and were killing yankees to get back at
you know the people that killed them or
whatever and i think in the original
they only needed to kill six people
because it was like they were getting
revenge for just the six people the six
union troops that came and killed all
the people in their town
this one and i was just kind of like
well the weird thing about the original
is that i said these the ghosts are
acting like they've done this before
even though it's only been 100 years so
this would be the first time that that
it happened whereas in this remake they
basically say uh this town pops into
existence for two days
every year
and it will keep doing that until
they've killed 2001 people which is
every single person that was killed in
the town so they keep coming back
because at one point like one of the
girls finds like this cabinet that has
like all these jars in it with like
hands and eyeballs and [ __ ] like that
and they're all like marked with
different years so this happened every
so i said well okay that makes a lot
more sense to me than just every hundred
years this is possible and some of the
ghost characters are like uh you you
know like you people killed my baby that
kind of stuff you know so yeah yeah yeah
so they're all getting vengeance for
each other and [ __ ] too you know because
they're they were a bunch of families
and uh the ghosts are pretty interesting
you know they got female ghosts
male ghosts
uh a little boy ghost who's not a little
boy playing a little role uh it's a it's
an adult pretending to be a little boy i
didn't really get that i guess they
couldn't get a little kid to do and say
the kind of [ __ ] that they needed
but uh two of them are like these
gone with the wind scarlett o'hara
looking ghosts and they're dressed in
kind of period clothes and they're
constantly making out with each other
and their cousins yeah we find out later
their cousins
and then uh which in the south didn't
mean anything
well everybody
everybody's cousins because
mary and your cousin that doesn't
necessarily mean your first cousin all
right yeah because they they if you look
at birth records they they didn't really
do that and the second and third cousins
were
married into your family so they weren't
really related to you that's usually how
it went and then
like i got cousins
that really i'm not related to at all
they're just kind of like
that
our traditions at least back in
mississippi up in places like heidelberg
and laurel
the children of your dad's friends are
your cousins yes so they're not related
to you
it's just that your parents grew up with
their parents and their grandparents
grew up with their parents but there's
no blood relations so everybody was [ __ ]
everybody just kind of calls each other
a cousin
they're friends of the family as a
cousin
you know so
that's a lot of times i think people
from outside the south get kind of
confused about that well the thing about
this movie though like i said is that
it's kind of playing with
the stereotypes yeah yeah so a lot they
make a lot of the jokes about the
stereotype and not just about
stereotypes about southerners but the
stereotypes of the northerners as well
yeah so you know everybody kind of gets
skewered in this and i would argue that
just like in the original and that's
what i mean when i say and this is very
much in the spirit of the original you
don't really
you don't really like
the the yankee characters like the
college students they all seem kind of
douchey yeah um and you know a lot of
the southerners like in the village are
creepy and stuff too but they're
slightly more sympathetic yes where they
are they at least have a lot more
character they're a lot more colorful
yeah the boy most of the guys in this
the the yankee boys are coming into the
south to take advantage of what they're
saying poor southern girls basically
yeah
that [ __ ] didn't fly
not as poor as you think it's not a and
[ __ ] not dumb either you know i mean
and they do kind of make a couple of
jokes about that about how they yeah
they just assume that that they're all
stupid that they're all stupid that
they're all poor yeah so the ghost ghost
female ghosts get back at him um yeah
that gap tooth girl like grows some
weird-ass looking [ __ ] male fangs or
steel fangs or something starts fighting
dudes dicks off yeah she was another
kind of southern stereotype you had the
two southern belles who kind of like the
upper class girls and then
her name was peaches and yeah you'd meet
you'd meet a girl named peaches here you
grew up with [ __ ] you could her name
wouldn't be peaches everybody would be
calling her peaches i knew a girl that
was called you yeah in the south you'd
see that she'd live in some trailer park
or live in something like that back in
the center i absolutely did a 70s [ __ ]
pizza
and uh peaches would probably look like
that too [ __ ] hot pretty much yeah
yeah like i said her what the one scene
of them like before that the one the
chinese girl got crushed by the bell
yeah um
where they were showing them all kind of
like dancing around and peaches she's
the gap tooth girl she hasn't been in a
lot of other movies she's only in this
movie this is pretty much it like we
looked her up yeah it looked her up and
[ __ ] it's just there's nothing really
in social media her she's got her own
social media she's just basically it
says that's why this is my only movie
and the gap is fake
yeah i can tell and everybody's like oh
yeah because i like the dick the cat's
kind of cute
but i painted it it was it looks cute on
her
yeah she looks good with it with again
very lauren hutton yeah but uh
belladonna or belladonna yeah more
belladonna than laura
and i want to say another southern girl
okay yeah uh so
yeah so the one scene where they were
running around and her
her short shorts they're denim or they
were made to look like denim man they
were like so far up and i was like oh my
god that poor girl that must be she like
[ __ ]
let's be like [ __ ] she's like she's
flossing her butt she's uh she's like
the stereotypical
[ __ ] deep south wild woman yeah she's
something she has kind of like that
short choppy hair yeah yeah not wearing
much clothes just running around in a
bra just run around and broaden like
tiny tiny shoes yeah barefoot wow yeah
so i don't think she was barefoot all
the time she would she wasn't barefoot
she had shoes because she was wearing
[ __ ] knee-highs knee-high stockings
yeah that's right yeah
but uh but yeah so that's kind of like
uh
and also and when you were talking about
like the southern belle girls before
their whole shtick was they would make
that nerdy guy yeah or you know he's the
nerdy kid the kid with the glasses they
were sadistic yeah yeah they would they
would like just be like make out with
each other and then
and then make you watch like but not let
you get involved yeah and then like if
he started then he started jerking it
and then they just called him a pig
[Laughter]
but yeah so
i don't know this was just like a really
fun
it's a fun updating and like i said this
is i'm not a huge fan of remakes but if
you're gonna remake something
then this seemed like a good candidate
because
you know the the original was so focused
around gore but they didn't really have
you know the the framework or the money
or anything like that to do the gory
[ __ ] that they wanted to do you could
tell and now that it was 2005 you could
take that and just like run with it and
just do crazy [ __ ] of like people's
eyeballs popping out and
severed heads everywhere and just bodies
being pulled apart like fresh bread and
it was just you know kind of like a fun
and like i said everybody just seemed
like they were having a really good time
with it i liked also
that and this is a spoiler uh but i
liked that they changed the original
ending a tad
because in the original if you remember
and so you know spoiler alert for the
original but that was 1964. come on um
you know and it's free to watch so go
watch it but in the original like the
two of the people get away right because
i said well it it's predicated on
people getting away because then they
have to find out because the whole time
during the movie they are thinking
everybody in this town is
real people and then they get away and
then they go to the cops and the cops
take them back there and in this case
it's just like a big cemetery but then
uh you know the original movie the two
just got away and were like oh that was
the craziest [ __ ] ever and then they
just like drive off into the sunset
whereas this one you think that's gonna
happen because they go back and they see
the cemetery and they're like oh my god
all these people were dead but then they
try to leave town and uh they get killed
yeah
they get beheaded by a [ __ ] barbed
wire thing yeah you think you think that
he's gonna make it because he makes it
through most of the movie because he's
actually southern and his last name is
lee yeah his last name was lee he was
living in he was just living in the
north but his family was from the south
was from south carolina so the ghost
tried to convert him back over yeah
which it kind of worked a little bit but
not really not in the end in the end
because they were gonna they were gonna
he had to they were gonna make him kill
his girlfriend that was the only way he
could yeah because or the girl that he
was crushing on yeah but she wasn't
southern yeah that was you know so you
kill her and [ __ ] we'll let you know
you will be good you know yeah but he
wouldn't do it but he wouldn't do it
yeah which you know would you really i
mean no most people would because ghosts
would just vanish anyway
yeah
they didn't know they were ghosts
no they didn't know until the next day
yeah even though i think like well a
couple of people did start to suspect
because as the two days went on like
everybody in the village started looking
a little bit more
ghosty or a little more zombie-like like
they'd start getting kind of like paler
or
you know their injuries or something
like that would start to be more like
pronounced or something so i thought
that was a nice touch too that as the
two days went on like they started
looking more and more like dead people
whereas they looked okay at the start
but yeah so i like that they changed up
the ending uh so you know so and nobody
got away and then you know basically
they're like well okay how many more do
we have to kill like before we can
because i think like uh robert england's
character gives a speech about you know
when they can rest so i'm presuming that
they're just gonna have to keep coming
back so it's a little bit like a curse
for them even though they're having a
good time until they kill 2001 people
and then they can you know go to heaven
or whatever the hell
uh so this was i think this movie
actually did not get a theatrical
release i think it just went straight to
dvd yeah they were not going to let this
play in a theater probably not even in
2005. i kind of was over the top in
2005. well but you know what though not
really like compared to some of the
other kind of like teen comedies that
we're going at the time i feel like this
is kind of in line with that but it's
just like super super gory uh the story
is the south [ __ ] troll in the north
and florida there's a bunch [ __ ]
comedy in here that the north wouldn't
[ __ ] like and the people that own amc
and those chains would not like that
humor one of my one of my favorite lines
was uh was the black guy saying because
i like those two like um
singers that like followed yeah people
around like singing that was like pretty
funny yeah the [ __ ] black dude the black
biker dude was getting trolled by these
two um bluegrass [ __ ] fiddlers and
[ __ ] they were fiddling and that
actually wasn't fiddly they had like the
tires there's guitar and a badger they'd
sing and [ __ ] they were pestering them
kind of like a mariachi band
at the damn mexican restaurant wherever
you go the damn band's following you and
yeah he was saying all kinds of [ __ ]
about crackers and [ __ ] that was like
crackers in my soup yeah
that made me laugh out loud that lie
yeah
there's some funny lines in this
some of the humor i think falls a little
flat like it's not quite as funny as it
thought it was but there are like some
actually like some pretty good [ __ ]
lines in here yeah um
i will say though that even though this
just went straight to dvd and i don't
really know how well it did but it must
have done okay because they made a
sequel to it oh all right in 2010 i'm
gonna have to see that one uh originally
i think that is also on to be if i'm not
mistaken i've heard it's terrible but i
don't know it probably is um
interestingly it's originally it was
supposed to be called 2001 maniacs the
beverly hellbillies
but then they later changed it to 2001
maniac's field of screams okay and now
interestingly i think this is what i
heard i don't know if this is true or
not robert englund was supposed to
reprise his role as the mayor
but i guess the movie took so long to
get made
that uh you know it just kept getting
pushed back and pushed back and i heard
that the director producers whoever
replaced him in the movie without
telling him they replaced him with bill
mosley i mean you know he's awesome he's
also an awesome actor
um but apparently it was supposed to be
robert england but various things uh
interfered so uh it was bill mosley
played the mayor also this might
actually interest you in seeing it even
more
uh you know the guy that was in it um
that was like the southern gentleman guy
that uh seduced the first girl cat that
got pulled apart yeah uh that part in
the sequel is actually played by uh ogre
from skinny puppy okay uh so there's
that
uh lynn shay is reprises her role in the
second one and the milk jug girl krista
campbell uh is in the second one too but
i think those are like the only
returning part at least the returning
major parts yeah but like i said i
looked earlier and i'm pretty sure the
sequel is on to be so we might watch
that as well just out of curiosity too
bad peaches didn't make a comeback i
yeah i don't yeah i don't think peaches
isn't the second one yeah tom really
likes peaches she's the hottest girl in
here yeah
that was that was her only movie though
i think she i think the i think it said
that she got married
but reality if you i mean this isn't
1950 it's like you know you get married
and you can't have a career anymore
who knows
who did she marry like somebody that
locked her in a cage maybe she got
pregnant and had a bunch of kids and
[ __ ] lost her figure you don't know
what happened i don't know
yeah it could have been that something
like that i just i always think that's
just such a weird explanation in 2021 oh
she got raised because
sometimes they're raising kids you know
i mean they don't have to end and i
don't think she was a full-time actress
that's true because i kind of feel like
if you're
probably a stripper if you're a big-time
actress and you have kids then obviously
you can afford to have somebody else
like taking and in reality reality if in
the south
especially back in the 70s and 80s maybe
wouldn't be so much and 90s it would
definitely a girl look like that named
peaches she'd be pregnant by about
6 17 18.
you know wouldn't stop her though
[Laughter]
she'd be 24 and she'd have two kids
already and she'd look just like that
working out at strip club sure why not
yeah hey girl got a girl gotta earn some
money somehow my my ex-sister-in-law was
one just like that that's what she did
she discovered working down the thing
[ __ ] i already had two kids well like
i said yeah girl got back i pay for
these kids yeah yeah their kids are very
expensive yeah hey you do what you got
to do baby yeah i'm not judging yeah uh
but yeah so if you're you know like i
said if you're kind of into
just ridiculous over-the-top gore lots
of titties yeah uh just very
inappropriate humor very juvenile humor
but still pretty [ __ ] funny gotta say
like some of it was pretty [ __ ] funny
and i was like i really liked all the
gore gags in this gotta say there's like
some really gore in this but it's really
good gore most of it's practical uh some
of the cgi's a little bit like a lot of
movies from this era were but you know
what are you gonna do uh but yeah it's
on to be if you wanna watch it and if if
you've seen it like let me know what you
thought about it in the comments and
that'll do it for this movie
retrospective we will see you guys on
the next one bye